can you guys just stop making such cool
skins for such a dog gun please
just don't be a coward and run the R8
look I've talked about this on stream I
think it was Swisher who had a theory
the R8 is actually good if all five
people run it at once you basically just
tag people with it the way you would
with a scout R8 is two shots to the body
through armor so if you tag The View top
mid with an R8 right to the Torso and
then your teammate just body shots him
as well you literally just delete them
from the server I actually don't think
it's that stupid the problem is that
you'd have to get people to select the
R8 for the entire match which
yikes